and when I then read that Axel Springer
Verlag somehow demands get you the
courage trophy or something like that also the pressure
from the press
that then put on day 1 or the day before the game
on the day of the game unbelievable pressure we
have to do something as a nation you
footballers have to do something  dear DFB you
have to do something
and then three weeks later you say something that is
not too much politics
then I ask myself who has
politics in many places even
companies there are people who say Rafael
Brinkert would destroy Germany
because, among other things, he
helped out  To make Olaf Scholz chancellor
because he is presumably behind the fact
that the German
national team made such gestures at the World Cup in Qatar that
you might also have been
responsible for the elimination afterwards, at
least he is the master of
attitude campaigns is building a new large
advertising agency and provides  very many
different controversies partly
projects I asked him about everything let's
talk to
Rafael has
brought Rafael together is uh we are both from
the Ruhr area although you are on the outskirts of the Ruhr area
by the lake if I'm
a bit more central with Essen but
otherwise  at least somehow the love for
the blue ones brought to
absolutely
that's one in Dortmund I'm studying
even if we
made Scholz and Friends for ten years so a
big
advertising agency then eight years Jungfer
matt in that time so you've got 18 years
right now with you  there is nothing
without a claim said after 18 years I was
then made of age there
were already some
activities that you did on the side
somehow tell me a bit like
looking at the first somewhat quieter
profession yes
you say the right thing so me
I'm from Münsterland and the outskirts of
the Ruhr area. I'm still extremely connected to the city
and somehow thought very early on
that I'd like to
do communication sports advertising
and
I think because of my average grades
the teacher told me at the time that
it probably wouldn't work, so if she
listens now I'll have to do it myself  I might say it
worked out a bit
and then I studied in Dortmund
Communications will be
studied again in the evening course in Cologne,
then after the before the flowers I
did an internship at Coca-Cola gregers yes
and um yes I actually didn’t go
back to the university then
she is in Dortmund but said
that if you now go into advertising
then this
communication specialist and intermediate diploma is enough and
I then applied to black fans
and was accepted
then I stayed there for ten years and
actually at some point the
call came from  Jeremy opened a fans
NRW back then when he was 30 and
then at 32 he said you come
from math too young and do sex and
Gee and Zalando and things like that
together with Jan rexhausen and that’s why
rabbits jump and um but
you have  yes, always like that, let's say
I've done a bit of
experimental projects next to
me, built Facebook pages for, above all,
who sells and everything like that, well,
we didn't sell them for the fishermen,
but we then donated them to the
benefit of them, so they were allowed to  Users
vote on that then get
50,000 to the Gerald Asamoah Heart Foundation
and um that was a page from fans for
fans at that time the club simply didn’t
believe in social networks but
said the club’s own forum was
enough and then I
actually opened the Bundesliga page  because the
Bundesliga didn’t have one at the time either
and then gave it up afterwards
and then, so to speak, the one really big
breakthrough can then be with Jung von
Mathe there, I think you
took part in the Merkel election
campaign back then, no, to be honest,
then Jeremy Format and  Thomas
did the filming location and we had a confession campaign with
Jungfrau mal Sports which we then open,
actually a celebrity campaign for
Merkel who confessed to Merkel
and we had
done the walk-in election program with Joachim, so
those were the two central points so
and  I'm from Haltern am See, that's
Munsterland, it feels like the CDU can
somehow exhibit on a broomstick,
then you're elected, you come from the
Ruhr area, that's more of a red color, let
yourself be and that's why
the situation back then was actually
that I think I was a man who  Middle am
Merkel was and is a woman of the middle
and then at some point I practically
went the opposite way from Mrs. Merkel,
who first wanted to join the
Social Democracy, who wanted to join the SPD,
but it was somehow too complicated for her
on site, okay, then here in the CDU
happened, so who knows how the
story would have continued, if she had
actually
become SPD chancellor, but for the
first time it became at least
really visible to me when you had the idea of
starting a sports marketing agency together with information,
so that was sports at the time  back then
together with Christoph Metzelder, with
whom we also grew up
it follows from
my intrinsic motivation ne I said yes
that I was always young so sport
is also an issue of sports communication
then Christoph
ended his career at the time like that and
Katja Kraus had
practically thought about what she could do
next  and then the three of us
went into the ring and
founded the agency, I as the operational
managing director, the two he worked as
foreign ministers as well as the outsiders,
of course, and then I
think we grew
from zero to 80 people in the first five years  The most
creative sports marketing agency
in Europe actually works very well with great customers
like dfb-d-usb with many clubs with
different personalities and that was
a lot of fun, yes, I think you
tried to
set up a player consulting agency back then, so
it became a classic yes
Volker Struth has already been a guest here, so it's
a huge business and you've
also seen that you
could somehow go in there, yes, that was
always something we thought about with Anne
Friedrich, then that's a field
that could possibly come from us Barack  it
could be from the
communication perspective umm we
actually said after a year
that's very far
away from the classic topic of
communication when you go into the right
player consultant business we did
n't touch it I think it was
also an exciting phase
to see again what individual fields there
are in this market, so I
can also do PR or communication for
a star, I'll do that
today with the new agency or
then of course go into stilmaking
and deal making was never really that
central topic otherwise you would have had to tackle it
from the beginning with someone like
before, okay
but then all the
developments Christoph Metzelder
that came later did you
find out about you actually
split up together then saw that I was
singular  Sport was no longer enough that
actually also a
power shift within the spinsters
makes gifted Jeremy Format
left Thomas Drehrad
left
and actually it was then that there
were also different interests I
actually somehow
separated from my girlfriend privately a new girlfriend
within the agency so
certainly a bit tense,
but actually I really wanted to be able to
do a lot more politics through this Merkel
election campaign, maybe a little bit
hooked on doing more than just sport back
then there was always that little bit of thought
then a political or
social unit within the
Junge von marktgruppe next to the topic of
sport or do I do that
outside of the group and that was
the second way and with start-up help from
Junge Format we actually started
the founding of brinkhart
Metzelder and  then after a year,
in the chronological sequence of three
weeks, we practically saw that
with a young format no longer makes sense
because there
was no mutual gain community,
but that one was in a
medium-term competitive situation
then with youth word sports and co
that  one individual other then also
more certainly also
wanted to go avenues, also what actually
concerns employee participation and stuff like that and yes, then came that with
Christoph, I remember we
said on Mondays we can do
sports marketing again after a year
with an agency that focuses on
politics and social  had focused
and yes a day later had then
taken it out of the game and again
less than 24 hours later
we actually had that then also a
notarial deed was yes it was clear if
such a rumor came up if there
might be something to it that
no longer makes sense  but together so
unexpectedly completely surprising so
nothing also hit these who caress the
topics so unbelievable so I don't know
was at the dfb academy in the evening
elevator and I
felt so open moving out downstairs and
my mobile phone exploded and
of course I was and
was shocked  It wasn't an easy time because something had to be
done with Jungformat on board with Christopher on board and four
weeks later I was on my own,
but at least it happened so
quickly that it
was somehow indispensable, so at that point in
time we were all together  very
clear in the decision-making process because it
no longer made any sense to
wait for a process that
might last 9 to 12 months that would take
the agency completely to life, so it was
an economic
necessity to take this step,
but of course friends
of Christoph also told me how to
do it  you do it why
can you drop him I can only say
so I explained it then
I understood it
and with Christoph and I it was clear at the
time because he
was of course involved in the business himself and we
also appreciate that  can and therefore there was
no other situation and
I don't think there is any
other discussion on the topic or do you
still have a little talk on my
birthday or about our
home club or something I have
n't seen you for a while but
I hope  that he might get a second
chance in society by
actually clearing things up, and
yes, but that remains to be seen, so he
held back very, very much,
unfortunately, communication, I mean, it's
actually surprising for someone who, so to
speak, who also felt communication,
always thought that  the one there with because
we are of course absolutely serious
but I thought at some point that was what would
say but not my hope
would have been clear immediately
because I believe that there is always
media damage and possible
pre-damage because such topics
will always be higher than  which is the
legal punishment,
but when you are in such a situation
I very quickly believe that the
lawyers will advise you on something and
that they are then the authority and not
possibly the communication people. In
any case, you then continued on your own
and you can or can do that
say today got really going well
so here it is today because
somehow you said 90 people yes 70
permanent employees then a few permanent employees free
but yes and there was the really big
breakthrough campaign of the election campaign for
Mr. Scholz that we did all at once
I think  The absolute breakthrough
was that I was then able to win Dennis,
with whom I worked 20 years ago
as an underwriter yes as a hyunda texts I
worked as a junior consultant.
Back then, I did Doppelherz when I was
24 or something and
I wanted to get him practically twice
and something with him  doing that was at
Jungfern Sport time that was at
Shorts Influenza NRW the time at
that time the situation didn’t exist yet
then it didn’t go very far and erm
five times in a row I think
creative number one was with Jungfermarkt
and then I told him so  it
's about time that
your 18 years are over it's about time that you
do something of your own and then
we founded the agency brings happiness
and that's why the biggest cow was
certainly Dennis to get
because he's in Switzerland and
does a fantastic job  The biggest campaign for the team
was of course for Olaf
Scholz how did that come about, are you then
or back then a few
years ago there was a smaller agency
I think Lars Klingbeil
somehow made the selection how did
you slip into it well it was  also
Olaf and we didn't know yet that the
candidate was there was actually a
pitch circle back then, that was still
in the pandemic, so you were almost
presented to the gyms and
the request came from Lars Klingbeil because
he was hoping for
a Merkel Jana  to win for the social of
democracy and that was
actually a bit of the
whole strategy, namely what
made Merkel strong can also
make Scholz chancellor what was the recipe for success in the end
that worked so to speak for Scholz
I think it was like that
Piece of the puzzle if one piece is missing then
maybe it wouldn't have worked it
was 1.6% more than Armin
Laschet so you can see how important
this decision was then
of course it was the person Olaf Scholz
our election campaign
relied on practical
personality election campaigns  So even
if we have a different party system,
but people want to trust each other
now and then and
also vote for people, and that's why it was
a personality election campaign, we
went through it radically, we
did it at the same time, I think
the election campaign was very red, even if you
can remember that  the posters were
visible from 50 to 100 meters they were
simple with simple wording we
of course had a competition with
Armin Laschet and Annalena Baerbock who
were possibly not well prepared either Olaf Scholz was in office
you only have to cross out four
letters from his business card
Vice-Chancellor
Chancellors do
that and the unity of the party
Last klingball and the team it was
actually like that we were a big
team and when was actually after heaps
for a mission and that was
to make Olaf Chancellor but I
took over first there it was  At that time, if
you remember, it wasn't like that,
so the navigation system was smiled at, so
I also heard the opinion of colleagues in the industry
according to the motto you're
crazy, why are you doing that,
you also have to know at the time
we couldn't do much, that was
Shortly after Christoph
was practically out of the agency, so that
the SPD somehow still trusted us at
the time,
and we still have him in the pitch but then there was
a constellation with
Thomas Koch as media expert
Theresa Gramm KODi  say
Nikola Lili made blue to which we
belonged so we also had a
bit of an expert team and the client
opted for this experiment and
then for a radical look and for
bold communication
which is actually lucrative then
campaigning for a party if
you have a profit-sharing yes oh
what does that mean it works like this if you are
actually chosen then there is another
bonus on top if agency
if you negotiate it early yes
okay so that was lucrative the rest
is rather no so are corporate customers
Of course, always more lucrative or also
car customers, no, that's not an industry
secret, but I think
everyone knows that, even with expensive film production and
co, um, we're interested in politics
and then also more interested in sports,
so it also follows a logic of the
agency and for us it has  then definitely
rewarded by the fact that we are
actually involved in success
and it was such a success bonus that
football knows or is there
already 100,000 million
of premium that's then but in the
dimensions
I don't know now so
no so there was  now no
premium,
what was there, so back then,
the SPD paint for 13 percent,
it was founded in 1863 and then we
said come on, that's a
good baseline measurement, this 18.63% and from there
you get a percentage point
maybe or will you become the strongest
force or will you become chancellor in
hindsight I made a mistake in the calculation
and I didn't
steal another topic about the strongest force ah
okay okay so it's missing as a variable in the bonus
because that's what
you've got in it, so to speak  the
political agency performance, so to speak, invented
a kind of intersystem I'm a big
friend of it because we're in the agency
that
wants to earn good money if the
customer is successful if art is
doing badly then I don't want to
take out or anything like that, that's where
I come from  now from a medium-sized company from
the bakery
family so I'm used to
sharing the booty together and that's why
I'm a very big friend with all
our customers from profit-sharing from
profit-sharing because we want to be
able to compete okay okay you give other customers
first say yes  there are a couple of examples, uh,
quite normal economics,
but then there are actually now
with the footballer we
work with, just like that,
football, that now also
publicly or speak about it, or may
I say I have that, so my
perception is you would be relative  I
would have lost a lot now,
because you footballers, as I said, draw
a bit of a red thread through
your life anyway, so you kind of
said Asamoah, kind of back then with
Zelda, the phase then you kind of did
a lot with the Turbo
when  he was even more active because he
also comes from Haltern, just like you, then there was
the phase but Friedrich, who then
somehow somehow
had a brief appearance at Information
back then and then Leonie, yes, so
Hansapark, no, well, social media
crown was certainly  with the longest
time actually which is extremely fun
what is a great friend will um
currently we are working today so
of course we made Wiki Corona
in the pandemic as an aid campaign with
Joshua Kimmich and Leon Goretzka and
many, as always, wonderfully involved
[music]
and  now up-to-date but now as a firm
mandate it's Thomasmittelsberger and
Leon kreuzgeil and how does something like that come about
so is that you once started
working with players and then
another one is missing or how do
you approach you or not partly
from the players' advice  then they
say, man, somehow we would like to
possibly consider the topic of marketing again in addition to the sales area
and that not
on a na level can someone use my Instagram
channel but on a level
as a communicative sparring partner so
and so it is with Leon too  I do
n't have to be empty and say which tweet
should be sent or where does he get
pictures from or the like, but it
's more of a qualitative discussion with
him with Christine Neubauer
and um team all the more and that's more like it
's actually a lot of fun
because it's
not  It's a customer relationship, it's
a great friendly relationship,
but it's not marketing either, so
it's communication, but it's
not like he's
calling adidas or other industries actually
want to work with him, that you then have
this network for that you
actually have then  the player advisor so
now in that case it will be
Christine neubauermann oh now then do it
I thought she would
only do one thing for one thing,
also in the team over everything but
usually it’s more like
the partners themselves okay  complete everything normally in the
end you
won and um then because the customer
relationship is over first or I
mean is it going to continue what is the
status yes we only
won one election at first we were not yet
chancellor no so there was  then
coalition talks where we of course from
the ancestors like that and
it's like that we
continue to work for the SPD now we work for the
SPÖ we work in Switzerland for the
SP um we're now doing the
state election campaign in Bavaria for Florian
von Brunnen also the SPD like that  but that
has to result from a
logic of trust and
I think that also characterizes the
mutual understanding of
communication who can do what what
kind of communication do you need
at some point there will certainly be a
European election campaign or
other mandates and we do
n’t have to now  Doing politics, but
I think
helping the right politicians
to communicate properly is a
lot of fun and also getting along with Lars because
the exchange or Kevin Kühnert or something like
that is still a
pleasure today and
we don't do government communication,
no, that's it again  there is also a
difference between the party and
government faction and the party communicates,
of course, primarily an
election campaign or a prominent
election campaign, let's say a few words
about the current topics of the there's
the discussion about it, you could
read that you might also be
working somehow for a vaccination campaign
or there is, well, I can't quite
understand what a photo like that explains,
we did the campaign
last year for the
Federal Government for the Bundeswehr for
this Ministry of Health and that
came about from various conversations there
are also various types of communication
the existing agency at that time namely
fans
and yes then we practically made these TV
spots and print ads or posters
for 84 days 84
personalities from Germany
protected why they protect themselves so
away from pointing fingers towards
personal responsibility and I think that
’s what it’s all about now  goes in the
pandemic or in the
breast pandemic phase that everyone
takes responsibility again
to protect themselves or to protect others
if they have the feeling they have corona or
are somewhere don't do it, but there were
those who were anticipating those in the room
somehow yes  they always come
from one of two directions that's also
a lot of opposition work,
you take note of that and of course
the conclusion is sometimes
it gets really absurd, so
when Nancy Feser is in a stadium with me
in front of 60,000, then
conclusions are drawn, she  is now
I would have told her what she should do
or so it really was
a lot of Grimm fairy tales and very little
understanding from journalists too so
I'm really disappointed in a few places
how superficial it is
but there are people that once we
come to  the sports topics uh more
up-to-date sports team at least as we
recently frozen but what you are saying
now there are people who accuse me of
destroying Germany I
destroyed Scholz and the chancellor and then
I put my arm in the stadium in single fiber
and the German
team  we recommended Leon Goretzka
to keep your hands off your mouth so it was for
the German elimination you would have
taken care of that too so there are people who
ruined our poster because you ruined it,
that was already three lies in
one sentence
so the truth is I
couldn’t have  or look to
make Chancellor but there is a
practical vote in the Bundestag about it
we could only win one election that
is the first the second is with VW
I have not spoken once to date
and also not easily
had a discussion about any
action in Qatar  or something like that, the
third thing is, um, that I
actually have nothing to do with the gesture
I was in the stadium, I saw her
the second she saw the world,
so of course we had considerations in
advance when working with the DFB
actually
rejected because they
actually took a shot at the One Love bin
and said that is the European
symbol with that we want to go and erm
we have to subordinate ourselves to that as a service provider
but that means in
dfb- so for him but that apart
before that
you can anyway discussion so before
Qatar there was a lot of fuss
about how you appear there how you
communicate there this bandage was
suddenly very relevant it is perceived
I think it is I perceived it as a fan
I perceived it as a
communication service provider  taken for the
defibr and
of course I also perceived it in an ideal extreme way
and I
think we pushed each other
up, everyone and the pressure on the
DFB in many places
to drive them into the corner he has to
do something now that politics  is not
able to do that and that I found
it this whole discussion the absurd of
the discussion gets to the
point best when I see Robert three
four months before we
somehow kowtow to the uh Qataris where he
bows to the Qataris  that we
hopefully get gas where we then I
think Markus Lanz requires
that the national players should please
take a stand so he demands
something from professional footballers that he himself
as a politician
cannot implement does not have the courage
whatever and I think that somehow so
then listen to it  really on I
think football also has this
connecting power of football that you
are not against something but for something
so you recommended at the time in the
talks let's just
line up here as normal it's
nothing to do here it's a normal
bandage no gestures  nothing, well, there was
a campaign like that and um it was
already reported in two places,
so I can say that there was
a campaign, they all go well,
you finally decided against it
because you then said you wanted to take part
in the  the dutch idea of ​​this one
love bandage participate in the european
community idea which is actually
totally correct that you said
you don’t want to do national things on your own
but you want to set a common example in the
european association with many other
nations
and then the  FIFA, as
dictatorships are common now, are practical or
like to do
DASDING then practically
collect somehow at the last second and then we don’t
play as the first nation but the
English and the English then
do nothing, so you have to understand
that the DFB then all of a sudden  is put
in a situation where he
may not be able to do that much anymore
and if I then somehow read the Axel
Springer Verlag that gives
you the courage trophy or something like that also the
pressure from the press
then on day one or the day before the
game on  day of the match
we have to do something as a
nation you footballers measure what to do
rather DFB you have to do something
and then three weeks later you say something that is
not too much politics
then I ask myself who actually did
politics in many places
like that and I think  I think we
all have to look in the mirror ourselves
and see who did what wrong, who
drove whom where, who
harmed whom with which statements
and again I can't
bow to the Qataris on the one hand and
then up  sitting on the secret couch
and saying now dear footballers, do
something, these are 18, 20, 25-year-old boys
who play football
and they were now the better
politicians to be I think that we
enjoy it the most when we
convey our values ​​when we
we also stand up for human rights
what the DFB does in an incredible
number of places what the deusbären
does in an incredible number of places where an
incredible number of companies
can learn a lot from so and in this
situation we have to be, but we
still have to appreciate things and
at the same time have to  the sport serves the
understanding of peoples, that means we
can promote our values, it does
n't have to be one lovepine, it can
also be other things, it can be a
heart gesture, it can be action
for diversity, action against
racism and co. so again and again
the public reach
to use the platform to represent values, but
each individual player has to
make that up for themselves, you can't say
the team has to do this and that now,
it has to
work more practically via gangs and it has to
be more of an invitation
to support such things but it must not
become a duty
the Leon and Goretzka made a relatively
attention-grabbing gesture in a
game against Hungary a few months ago
such a heart-crate
that was also a bit of an issue
because in Hungary we say that  it was
the euro so exactly one goal was scored
also a very important one if i
remember correctly there
is a homosexual legal situation
is also a bit problematic then rafael
brinkert who gives tips so to speak
and the situation 0.0 okay
that is 100  % Leon Goretzka, I think
maybe 2% Thomas Müller
because these guys were sitting on the bench and
somehow saw the situation,
also with the fan block, they have the
discussion, they are responsible players and
Leon is someone who is
incredibly political and
has a strong opinion  and it's not just any
agency, it's not just me,
it's 100% Leon Goretzka and that's why I have so much
fun
sparring and
discussing things like that, it's important to him
to advocate for justice a
bit too  the people of the Ruhr area
actually go for international understanding
and things actually somehow
relate the subject of religion and Co. to football clubs rather than
believing that's the lightness
of the Ruhr area and I think we
can all learn a lot from the Ruhr area,
let's just say a few words  let's
talk about it again now but Wiki
Corona it was also an
idea from the two of them and you then
implemented it, but only in the
case of what was very specific that the two
said they wanted to do something and
called me and did  said Rafael,
you already have thoughts about what we can
do in the pandemic, so we can
help with a donation, what makes
the most sense and it was
actually the case that I said give
me 24 hours, I'll think
about it, but classically
I am  I used to get out of it
somehow in the morning at 6 a.m.
so the night before I had
a
really bad title that’s so
I don’t have any
orientation anymore but it was easy if
then it never would have worked so well
but then the next morning
at 5:30 a.m. I had the thought of
Corona and when I had the thought of
Wiki Corona as a name,
I knew that this platform
worked and the thought was then
direct help for
self-help from the boys, so how can you not,
for example, donate a million to an institution
but how can you
possibly make more out of a million,
we made six and a half out of it and
how can you
help clubs directly on site,
for example the Tafel in Bochum
Gerte or
in Hamburg's Schanzenviertel an
institution that
practically has money worries in the pandemic and how can
you give them help like that and that with
this help we had collected a total of six and a half
million and it
benefited 700 institutions and clubs
how does it work because that is generally
independent of your clients
hopefully I'll be totally amazed then
I'll watch a football game in the
stadium somehow  some players and
minutes after the game are already on
Instagram or something like that the photos of the
game with caption and everything is
partly stories I think awesome they
must have posted immediately after the shower
or or even earlier
then teams do that or do
many many  Jobs make teams like that it
's like that and it's easy in
professionalization as well as in the
business offer of player agencies
and so on or also of
sports marketing agencies is the
sub-area
I can now only speak for the players
I look after or something and
so that makes it 100  % yourself and
you don't have anything ten minutes after the
game, but sometimes even the
day after, if at all, or an
hour later, but of course it's also the
case that the clubs provide the agencies or
service providers and the players with
photos immediately  So
every club there is money, the photographers
on the sidelines, there are
definitely photographers from the club, that means
the pictures are not the topic
and that we then
actually take them individually, so there are also
match day postings and so on, that's what's going on
now  the graphics for it so
I don't think that Jammer is
more of a must, I think he's a
footballer right now, but I don't think
that a photo, I've been sitting there and
thinking about what his matchday posting
looks like, we colleagues do that and yes, in
general you have one  high
affinity also together so
staging around sports so one
topic I don't know who that
was clarified is also yours with the connections
is that at the
time Hertha BSC was like that in the USA
that the football game often
knelt to against  Police violence
against
dark-skinned yes fellow citizens
to draw attention to fellow citizens
that he was japanex and famous way
that started and made more and more at that time
and we can
observe the phenomenon in the USA that he
said the players were engaged all of a sudden
but had BSC in
Bundesliga and then knelt,
so to speak, before the game and
everyone was flabbergasted, surprisingly and then
in the background there was a bit of the
thesis in the room that could
have been rafabrik again because you would have advised at the time
[laughter]
the future could be heard  Berlin
written that I think is still
burned everywhere on the game, I just didn't know at the time
that it was Union money
[laughter]
[music]
so we were going to be in close
contact back then we did various things
together and so it makes
sense that we  we also
talked about it there is this
claim that was also controversial in Berlin
I think you invented Germany’s oldest startup for Hertha because
there was a situation where you
actually said this up down and
then get up again and
tackle it again what yes  where is there a duality
between startups or business
and unsportsbusiness in general,
the positioning back then was on the
thermostata I'll deal with that
now, that wasn't really my DNA, but
we as an agency helped develop it, yes,
okay, okay, so the future belongs to Berlin
I think it's really good and
he just has to implement it you're
still worth working no so you
only follow the whole agency from afar a little bit
actually also a
different focus of course there's sometimes
the inquiries where we do something small
or  but
now nothing is up-to-date anymore, not to the same
extent and the DFB is also not an
easy customer, so it's a big association, of course,
but the external presentation has been
in the last few years, I think
you can't be optimal,
yes, there were also changing presidents
and customers  a lot of unrest in the
association also unrest in the world and
this multiplication is I think
it is always difficult to
communicate there wasn't this
sporting success of Anna zu namazi
I have now I've been working for
the DFB since 2013 and we had our
amateur real  professionals so an
amateur football campaign we have
made various CSR stories
climate protection against racism and so
on we only took over the other national teams
this year
and 21 academy we do
various other jobs I still find the DFB I
can only say in many many places
that the  DFB makes a great customer he
is that's really fun and above
all there are great projects that you
can accompany that now bring more
money than working for Mercedes or BMW
probably not
but you do a bit that
I'm convinced it's fun yes and  I only want to
do things that I enjoy
the jam the team is yours too
no he well we only had the
national team this year
he was replaced so it was
taken down in 2014 he was instinctively
staged or even then I used
it then  I also only read it, like
football fans, I knew
or of course I also noticed
that people in Germany were always fiddling with it,
so I think it's
a logical consequence to say
that it simply means a DFB team or
national team
[music]
is a correct one  Taking the decision down
and especially if you
want to approach them with the spectators again in Germany
that they want to emotionalize,
changing a festival together again
helps to break them down and that was
a small barrier, certainly in an
international context, the
team will up  so called today
who does his really well from his
point of view so in sports communication
so if you look at a lot of things
you are now a player close to it that
is now represented by a wide variety of clubs associations
who is there are
role models I’m looking somehow James
or  so of course now is a simple
answer because he's huge there's
another example okay these are people who
use their platform super which
makes good communication I think it's
incredibly crass the lattern
Ibrahimovic did it very much I can very
angular but always Satan so I remember
his  Ad when he
moved to the States to L.A. and then
he doesn't say so L.A. so great that you should, but he
did the whole ad for a whole time
in the ehm something similar times I
think it's done then
said so
welcome to Satan so  due to this
exaggeration, it has a very high
level of maintenance and it suits it as a brand,
so it has a very unique
character that goes its own way, where you
always encourage
me to become an agency
he too has a great
network definitely
he does it as a personality brand
but that only suits him then and you
always have to deliver ne
very well there are of course also
so Ronaldo has of course
done well for a decade he now had to do
the Saudi  -Arabia change somehow from
the German perspective of course
not from the global perspective I do
n’t know what he has in mind for the
next 30 years
and you can see the strategy of
Saudi Arabia behind it that they are now
somehow Messi Ronaldo so they do
n’t want a sporting nation  will they
also want to bring global events to the country
one can now have different opinions about it
but it is definitely
work if you think it is
improbable that they somehow
want to do something in Germany and
speak to you ok I wouldn't
work for Friedrich Merz either  so
yes
Sauerland and so or from the corner so
[laughter]
well then sometimes has a
worldview that can
be assigned to the Middle Ages
okay
um there are a few other
examples says that is somehow
outstandingly well done or otherwise just
not interesting yes  there are
always little ones so in
this long-term story St Pauli
you kind of called it five six years ago
you always liked to call it that
meanwhile I don’t think it
can be that fresh anymore there are
of course other times too
I think there are  many
academies can still actually be managed there
is still huge
potential for the DFL as such
in international marketing to
show this USP of Germany compared to other nations, namely
this 50 + 1 story and co. I
think that's one, so there is
a lot  many chances,
a very short Paris 24 makes it
very good right now, so I
think the Olympic Games are actually clear as an event, so the PC is of course, I mean, the Olympic Games
are doing it very well, so I'm
always surprised that somehow I live
St Pauli too and on the one hand
you also have families who said
somehow turbo capitalism
football everything doesn't work like that then
you see in a year later the kids
with uh Messi and Qatar
were run around on the trick think so I'll go exactly
the opposite of the values ​​they can and
actually preach, so that's where
this battery belongs, I think I'm
a bit too insecure, so Messi
and Ronaldo are, I think I'm measuring
some tax evasion here, and
all Ronaldo issues, there's also something in the
room at various
levels  and still they are the
stars are getting hit also has
unbelievable coal which has never hurt anything it has
hurt you in many places has also closed many doors
ne you have to say that somehow
this country hopping doesn't come
from tremendously at least with Ronaldo
for example, where we then deliberately
wanted to get out of Spain in order to
practically avoid this tax scandal, we
now have this scandal again at
Juventus Turin, well, football is
loaded with those
that have nothing to do with the 11-on-11 game,
but Ronaldo and  Messi
simply
put their stamp on this sport globally for 15 years
and of course they don't have this
language barrier in many places, so
they come more
Hispanics plus England then you've
probably
covered three quarters of the world somehow more or less understandably
the Spanish league follows the
English  Liga then there are other
names that you can somehow imagine
as an expert as it is nice in the room that you
could maybe go to the Bundesliga too Ronaldo or last year about
when she
went back to the menu or wanted to go
then stayed  is and
his window where it looks like he
could really maybe get a Bundesliga I would have thought it would have been great
for the Bundesliga
for the club that would have taken it
or for the cabin as it is then
called it would have been more difficult
because the cabin cares  then,
of course, such a personality then
for
excitement and we saw that at
Manchester United in the last
six months what excitement
a Ronaldo can actually talk to a
team where he
is no longer a regular player was maybe put off the
bench now it’s um
changed or is it also then you
canceled a contract with Menu and
manuus has been playing free ever since then
lost 32 yesterday I think somehow against Arsen but is somehow
suddenly top 3 club in the UK again
after my last year actually
behind the far  has
fallen short of expectations but Ronaldo is
now 96 37 38 Messis 34 um yes, although
their last World Cup are
you following what is
being done at Victoria Berlin there are a
wide variety of business women and also
sportswomen so I find it
extremely exciting with Lisa Vera  is
a former employee of
mine who is now practically the head of the
association or coaching
Laura can be called with blackish from
who made the design of the Elbphilharmonie with us
come back from the digital world
participate again exactly so they do of course
but so they just have
women  one exactly but the design so
the consistency with which they
want to do it and say we want the
club then in Berlin that's
remarkable the question is how long
Union and yes it
's been spun off
meanwhile like that but the question is
what does Union do what  makes it harder what is
to be expected in the next few years
it will be an exciting field knowledge in
general your then your view of
football is that the sport in
Germany at least can continue to grow
or are you skeptical I
mean it also pulls the
podcast here a bit  I've talked to a wide variety of protagonists over the last few years
and it's not so clear to me that
football in Germany is going on somehow
and then the Bundesliga is still okay,
but we're actually learning through
digitization that big things
are getting bigger
and accordingly I believe that
football is still going on  is not in the
border areas that you
can get a lot more out of the brand can
get out of the brands can
get out of the sport that
the proceeds are certainly not at the end
you have to state them carefully you have to use
the brands like any other brand
keep practically
reinventing, developing, but
especially the topic of
women's football, as in the next few years,
this 50 + 1 will be extremely important, this controversial regulation,
which is why
clubs or companies in Germany still
have to remain a club country somehow
and in others it's different, that's how it will be
you just said to work out the core of the brand
and say
that it should definitely be retained,
logically and it has to be placed at the forefront
so that we can differentiate ourselves from it
we are all friends
of USBs, that means how can you 1
communicative how can you
communicate unique product properties in the best possible way and that is
a product property that
distinguishes itself from Italy Spain France
what is um well
but you still believe
against this strength  the premier league
get against these huge funds
probably it's just a small
element and fight against it but it wo
n't be enough exactly so from
several elements so
against the premier you don't get that
that's with seven my boots
contain that I can barrier and
something like that, that's why it was
a lot easier for her and
she was there at the right time, so
when digitization really starts, I
think we have to be careful that
France doesn't overtake us, Italy
overtakes us, so Spain and England are
far away,
but then we have to
we have to maintain this third place and
we have to do something for that but we also have to get
stars back into the Bundesliga i
sometimes have the feeling that we have such an
allergy to
stars we don't create stars at all so Manuel Neuer if he
switched to Real Madrid once in his career  will then perhaps
become Chelsea Vera global bigger
star probably still can
probably still make a zero behind
his followers Numbers like
Mesut Özil did, for example,
we have to learn that we can
make things big again in Germany,
it doesn’t just affect him  Sport
also the economy and politics that we
also celebrate for things that we
see the glass half full and we tend to
be more critical with ourselves than with
others that certainly helps to be
objective but that does
n't help us to find revenue um
Models and marketing structures and
50 + 1 is one thing, but the other is,
for example, the issue of the cooperative principle,
no, we are both Schalke now,
why
180 million liabilities, why do
n’t you seriously examine the issue of the
cooperative and if you then
have arguments, our sheik are
160,000 fans  then I find it very,
very exciting, so it will
work like this. 160,000 fans would
then pay something like 100 euros
or something like that, or probably
then it would be
1990.04 and then there might be
super fans who would then sit for a stadium
or something like that  Pay €190,000
so I think you
can certainly get at least €180 million with that
you could there was already a
principle of long-distance loans and something like that yes that
would have to be reissued I think you are for you could
make Schalke debt-free very quickly yes via the
members yes
okay  what do you think of
another one let's do a USP for
the Bundesliga that you could work out
we've discussed a lot straight stadiums
ne that are great encounters that are um
also always exciting see yesterday the
last few days then Cologne 1-1 against Bayern
and so on  so things everyone can win against everyone
else somewhere in the end
Bayern will always be
champions somehow but other than that the
competition is very lively
Eintracht Frankfurt has made an incredibly
great journey in recent years
HSV will be back so
yes HSV will be this one  year
and the city is also longing for it,
so the sport, I can
remember I moved to Hamburg,
HSV played European games and what a
great feeling it was
to live in this city then, even in a
summer month like that or something like that  you knew there
is another major European power
that is playing against HSV today in an
unbelievable way and I would
like that again and that's why we should
all somehow not care whether you're a
Polly or HSV fan now you should
be a sports fan of this city like that and
HSV  is that I'm definitely one of the
places of fulfilment, tell me
what we're talking about where we're
talking so much about these digital topics, back to
the
federal election campaign, you just
talked about posters that were red
and so the slogan is they were put up
and stuff like that  did he not play a major role digitally
not the one that you probably rent out as an online marketing
rock star okay
no actually is so that for so
I like this
terminology doubt wants content
so that means a poster just stands in the
way
and I can get through  Digitization can
even make this poster
movable and so on Election campaigns
are a bit anti-cyclical because there are
suddenly posters in areas
where there are no other posters, which means
they get in the way
and as a result these posters take and
then become  about 450,000 all over
Germany with Olaf Scholz they get
a blast you drive through the city and
you notice it's just and not a circus
in the city but there's an
election in the next 6-8 weeks and that's how
we won the election through this
radical simplification of the look in the
messages and in the digital strategy
we have looked for the greatest common denominator in many places
instead of
dividing the
target groups that means now if
you win the election that's why I can
say now
we had, for example on the poster
[  Music]
now affordable housing
if I only show Olaf Scholz big and
the background is only red
then I give very clear
instructions that are just as good for the big city
as for the small town
for a student as well as for an
older target group for seniors why
because then  there is only affordable housing
and hidden behind affordable housing
everyone understands their own
world but if I show Sinus and
then show a home of their own in the background
then I mess up a bit in
communication because I should
actually have to show all target groups
I would have to have five  six
posters make that means and that
in general what I would wish for in
the communications industry that we
look for big common denominators and
then simplify it radically simplify
life campaign is easy I appreciate
myself but everyone has it on their hard drives by now
so what was that probably the claim  you
made the most worn in
Germany after
is known by most people
and there were many but social policy
for you for the SPD is already
very
popular I would say our
amateur real professionals I still found
great the concept we
made together  do sport germany
actually create a product brand for the deusb
that would then be such a so you want
me then it’s
often also great copywriters from the team at United
at Football who actually have the
application campaign for the
2024 European Championship for Germany
so United at Football got the pinch
I wrote like this and many other
things somehow came about
together as a team, so
sometimes there is this one
primal father, sometimes it is then, however,
that there are several people working on the
topic and you also
come to this solution together, now there is a
whole one  A number of agencies that are more of
a PR area than a story do
that
and the team
who also coach people very well
and do social media for CEOs
Entrepreneurs is also what you
can imagine, I mean you do it
in a way  for for football professionals but
I don't know about others now
basically yes it depends on the
type so we are now so we do
n't do classic
new business now but we answer the
phone that means if someone
calls then they say they will be happy to do so
then let's talk about it,
think about what to do, so last year
we worked with Jan Ullrich for a long time, e.g. we had
this wedding retour
also retour de France and so on when we
had thoughts about
what has become
a film now he is doing it
with other partners but now  So
this thought back then for him too
to practically
get rid of old varieties or something and to kick himself freely
in the truest sense of the word
or something yes that also arises in the
common together and quasi
give number to the other side and says
human yes or  then in that case then
Dirk Baldinger has his personal
contact now he does a lot with Paul Ripke
so from there everything is fine
but there are other people so
you say they will actually
do something good for them or that you would have them
or so
I think no, I don't know specific
people, I probably would
n't want to name them now, but there
are many
who can communicate better, who
can communicate more easily, who
can communicate proactively, no, we
had the tank discussion in the last few weeks,
which Olaf Scholz is now
outstanding  probably solved
but in between there was also somehow
this vacuum and every vacuum wants to be
filled. that
quickly feels like propolists or
populist statements or
false statements
konrad-adenauer once said so many
things he doesn't even discuss them with
himself  I actually found a
nice
sentence for a federal chancellor because I
think every federal chancellor is okay, so
last night I was at an event
where it was said that
Fridays for future might have been the most successful
marketing campaign, at least in
Germany, in the last few decades
Idea and also
nice because it says Fridays for future
Set something for something and not against something
and I think in order to be successful in the long term, to
get caught and
start a mass movement, you prefer to be
for something, so back then in the
refugee crisis in 2015,
for example, we had  My campaign then also
started as a private commitment that
said everyone has the right to
human rights that was his
celebrity campaign with various people
with power campaign on the internet but she did
n't say yes or no to refugees
because you can actually do that or there are
there are different positions
not also in the political camp and so
on but if you say everyone has the
right to human rights
you don't get it
so Fridays for Futures the important thing is
before
the sentence namely you are for something
but whatever they do they
naturally provoke  also somewhere with
strikes and now with others it goes
well beyond that but
you are actually only provoked
with demonstrations and that is peaceful
and the demonstrations are even
registered it is not the last
generation that is the difference
between Fridays for future and  why
I would rather send my children to the
last generation than to the last generation but in general I
also tend to accept a bit of
provocation so if you know you too
if you work with you a lot of
things he's awesome he's good but
he's not just
me either  I think I'm very simple I
think I'm very simple so there are
also narrators like that I wasn't there there were
somehow
industry events where you
stood at the front of the stage and
insulted the audience
nope I probably just
nope I haven't until now  I
often like to speak plainly yes
[laughter]
which is not easy these days
yes but I think it also needs
a progression so it also needs
a progressive force to
not defend the status quo but
to question it  I think I'm
very happy to be someone who questions the status quo
because he wants to change things
so and again I'm not one I
'm not one for an
administrative wing and if customers are
somehow only looking for vicarious agents
then we're the wrong
agency  I want to
make a difference, that's why I say to all
our customers, I want to have the before and
after aspect, that means I
want to improve something, I don't
just want to make money, it's a
different business model to
make money, you would actually also be
perfect with his young companies  Startups
fit and
accompany them at the beginning, so to speak, when they
maybe have even less money Success-
based billing you just
said at the same time you also create a bit of
attention for things
that are difficult to advertise or or
without large funds through a
certain provocation beforehand you have afterwards  so
many salamanders
not at all because at the moment
we are more concentrating on politics,
social and sport
economy we haven't yet
developed that much practical as a topic
can maybe come over time
but in Germany there are
also many good ones  Agencies, so it was
the specialization that we
practically want to start with
that
will probably happen a bit
later with the growth that we also
take on more economics, but again,
either the
phone will ring then I’ll answer it  and then
we'll listen to something, but I'm
not doing any kind of broadcasting or I'm
writing to 5000 marketing people now,
let's imagine that,
fortunately, a little bit doesn't do anything and
you manage it in sales with
your passivity in sales, so to speak
in the end about 10 million that
well this year we had 9
million with Switzerland and um
that's within now we
just founded the agency with
Dennis 21 22 we became agency of the
year now we have 23 so if you like
that  want is the track was
pretty good right now but we don't have
sales targets we have
quality we don't have quantity targets
but quality targets we
want to do good stuff we want to
do creative, strategically intelligent work
that also has a certain amount of publicity
and the consequence of which is
automatically a demand  to us
and a magnetism and that's
a thousand times better for me to do good stuff
and the phone rings
because then when someone calls who
already has a concrete plan
than to go to 37,000 events somewhere
and can do visits like that, I
probably still don't have a
business card like that and
so on  So we tend to think about things like
how can we somehow yes if
character I'm probably like
six I was allowed to
work for sex somehow for six seven years that
was incredibly fun with
Erich six at the time then somehow and um that's
why we want to
be a bit like 60 for sure but we
want to do good stuff so also a
lot of social work we will have employees
share in the profits they get just
15% of the profits
automatic percent of the profits for
charitable purposes then we still collect
a bit of money reserve have
nowhere and  Credit, that's very
Hanseatic, so if you hear 9
million now, you have a lot,
so the last few years have been very good,
also thanks to profit-sharing, and we're
already talking about a return of 10 to 20
percent, so that the employees
get a profit-sharing  and we
also find out which ones at all
we need 15% profit we
also had good ones for two years so let's say
he 20 then distinguish 29 million
results are then realistic
but okay it's almost a
bundesliga salary for you
yes and bad
so football has  it's not enough,
so I have to
somehow close the gap, no, the agency
works well, but of course we are
also in the investment phase in many areas,
we want to do good stuff,
your goal is to make such an agency bigger,
so I think it's in
Germany so that
no new agencies have actually been founded for decades,
most of which have become really big, there are a few
exceptions, but most of them have
sales of around 10 to 15 million euros, so they are
slowly growing back there
and then they are taken over or
then will  sold very seldom does
anyone still manage to build an agency that
goes to the 100 million turnover limit on its own and even beyond
that actually has hardly seen anything anymore
maybe because then the reasons
simply say the money um is the one
goal you have that is really the
Bringing dimension or doesn't matter now
I don't care at all, so I'd rather have
I do creatively excellent work
for great clients and only have 20 people
than
brag somewhere because I have 150 or 200
or 500 people and I know I
actually only do 80  Percent sucks, so
the advertising agency business model
also happens because you
actually only put a little bit of
10-15% in the shop window
or then do awards and so on,
we don't take all the districts like that and
we only say what's in the shop window of others
should be our day-to-day business, we
just don't want to make any customers where
we have to do
work that don't make a social
contribution, that don't
involve a transformation in the sense of an
eco-social market economy
and that don't make a contribution to the
common good, but that we
can afford it  then
somehow that maybe the merit
of the last 20 years also brutal work
are there any customers who
think of something for the will there are
customers who
come up with something else for
[laughter]
but there are many so I love  for
example as a brand, also as a story
Patagonia, for example, that's why
I find this cooperative model
extremely exciting, so how can we
as an agency
develop even more in that direction,
and why aren't we enjoying it at some point the day
after tomorrow, so things like that
I deal with  just a
lot maybe that's even
if you have kids who are 10 or 11 who
are totally different or something like that the
challenge you also every day so and
the questions like dad what do you do and
if you I always said at some point
I want to  I can tell my kids
I did something sensible but do
you think that this whole
discussion is sort of a result and Patagonia is
I also think that if
you don't do it I think if you
do it right away because the founder really
decreed that his shares be donated to the foundation
and then simply waive a lot of money
privately but do you think
that in general this purpose marketing
Rewe makes it very strong, for example,
that they say we don’t print
anymore and or we cancel the
partnership with the DFB yes but
that was natural  also somehow ne
so get free applause once ne
I don't know if you should be able to deal with a partner like that with
a long-term partner
with whom you
have benefited for years and that's why
I thought Rewe would have it if they
were so purposeful  you can
simply let the contract expire quietly at the
end of the year, which
was planned, so I don’t need to
pick up the one with the free app, so there are other
companies, or is it a general
concept that you think
you would recommend brands for so
strongly  to position in the sense of
purpose or sustainability often where at the
very end in the
current world the companies also have to
somehow make a profit there are
other influences you can’t always
remain true to
that does it make any sense at all, so
I think the social business the  next
big singles and in the past
also historically brands
always had a half-life of a maximum of
80 100 years so then there was this
obvious conclusion if
Polster or Tesla really were the new VW
then
viva con Aqua might actually be the next
Apollinaris and I think  it has
something to do with prosperous markets where you
can afford it but that this
ID function this year in the 20th
century the ID function was
a bit like the car key
that became the smartphone of course i
think the ID function is that
the kids through globalization the  yes
then this transparency as well or
digitization which
still demands this transparency it
no longer matters which clothes you
wear it doesn't matter how you
consume and I find that incredibly
exciting this is also a field in which
I would like to develop extremely further,
i.e. social business  so how can you make
a positive contribution to the common good
with what you sell and
also
employ employees to make a profit
and used to I believe that
this will be a premium price so
you can then just go for certain
brands that
have this social benefit or these  are
actually built on such a business
that the higher
profit measures are okay, so they are an example,
but there is
another logic because the founders
really decided to give up money.
There are other examples of what within
the system you can brand well and
credibly,
yes I  I think, for example, a brand like
Adidas or something like that sometimes tries
to make individual products out of it,
or keep making product lines
I think it’s all the beginning of a
much larger debate, namely what
means  you can buy the adidas logo on your
shirt if you're really honest with a
clear conscience,
the brand a b c d e and this discussion
will take place and again when you
have kids who are 10 11 and have exactly
this basic discussion with you
that says maybe I want to  don't
have a level at all but it's not an
elite discussion will say yes in
certain circles in
the communication industry about it of course
somewhere media but culture business
wealthy people
in Germany that's the way it is when you look
at the end of Primer or H&M and so or
not
Ski in
that you know that  it or that you ca
n't imagine that there is somehow
just very little sustainable
booming, yes, but that's exactly what's happening,
that the premium brands
are highly attractive
and that practically the entry-level brands
are highly attractive for other reasons,
keyword also fast fashion and so
on  that the middle section is
actually falling away more or less
like that and you notice that in all places
okay but it's still more would have
said the population simply I don't
care I don't think I just need
some new fashion here for little money so give me here
what is there but again we have
23 now what will happen when we are in 32
what will be the discussion when we are in 2040
and I believe that the
question is what strategy do
you have do you have quantity models do you have
qualitative models  so and I believe
that such business
will be incredibly interesting even for the
general public the
question is there are there are also in
so in 2023 things are
unthinkable that would have been conceivable in 1970 let's
talk about language let's talk
about
further development  of markets and so
on
what is now 20 what will the world look like in
if the whole world knows that the
t-shirt with so if you don't have a logo now
okay but if the logo has an
identification function and if this
identification function is negatively charged
then  don't you dare to let
yourself be seen with it in the entry area
either, so adidas didn't have the
West straight discussion a
bit too, ne then you notice which
cations in view can have such things
and I just find the topic
the next pixing is such  So
not business I don't think I don't believe in
meters it would be otherwise what I believe
such business so real world such
business
tell me a few words about your
current hobby project or a
long-term hobby project in TuS Haltern that
's also a football club in the
currently fourth league
we were in the regional league
then you are still active on the side and are
you trying to get this club
somewhere out of nowhere that’s
a bit of a gimmick for me yes
that’s the youth club yes from me
Benedikt Höwedes Christoph Zelda Sergio
Pinto the many bundesligas
number 5 is alive
so that's just my home club
and I was allowed to play there for years
that my hometown we are there right
now has main sponsors around
this club
with my brother's bakery
and we actually have under the time
then when we looked  how
far can we then practically how
far can it go how far can we
develop the football club were
we in the regional league played against
Rot-Weiss Essen
11:1 so no politics
defeat
then but practically in this one because
regional league was for us  always clear we
want to remain an Akinator
with a great youth and we are well on our
way there we
then voluntarily dared to withdraw from the
regional league why because there
are professional conditions so
the players somehow train
five times a week plus games you hate
suddenly a stuff also an
organization to make these games
you have security games that means you
have the police meeting and co because
then the windows of Rot-Weiss Essen or
Prussia Münster or the like
are just so numerous and sometimes
also
grouping or  So then when
the police
actually played through as a security game and that pushed the
club to
its limits a bit we weren’t allowed to
play in the Stausekampfbahn but
we had to switch to
Wanne-Eickel or
in an or wait time  '09
and
then we said
we're not going to play the game anymore with
Christopher, of course Mercedes, then we've
practically not been with them anymore
and uh, based on the situation,
we then took the crisis
as an opportunity to reinvent ourselves
and said  we are the Athletic
Bilbao of amateur football so the
bild-bauweg that meant nothing more than
yes we no longer have these
financial possibilities ergo
we are taking the step back and going even
more towards the city our star
is the city is the claim now and
try to put the city in the foreground
try to have an active club life
as more ambitious in the villages
one
the current trainer is now also
teaching employees with us is lucky
so we then have a close network
of press spokesman is social media
manager with us and we always
said  that agency so yes we have the
headquarters in Zurich and Hamburg but we
have satellite in Haltern am See there are
now four five people
working for us in general in NRW and
maybe Berlin will come next
so and therefore for us actually
very very well  Trainer von Haltern
am See has also left your place,
yes, so we are, if you are being
followed like this, then
the moment will come when you will leave
advertising or agency life
and lead yourself into real
politics or  yes in sports politics
at least or somehow an
association activity changes to the active side in the
long term here in
the medium term short term no but in
the long term yes it is I think a
logical consequence so it could be
that we can still spend as
Schalke president maybe
or there is not everyone president
The day and the board of directors are careful that there was
no mystery that two
years ago there was a specific question in the room
as to whether I
would like to become chairman of the board
at least on the financial level
together with my colleague
I would have been more of a tackle department
like that and
I would have
enriched the Bundesliga immensely back then, so
I would have read it in the newspaper and
maybe got a WhatsApp from you
and would have said wow, now it’s ok
from Rafael Brinkert Schalke
business but that has to be
put on now yeah too bad
I'm interested in no
well we have a lot of plans for the agency
we have a
lot of plans with our customers to be able to do that back then
you'll
have to shut down the agency then yes  but I also
said I wo
n't do it like that at the time, but who would you have
rather what would certainly
have been a different situation, but
who knows what will happen in five or ten years,
but now the agency is
incredibly fun and now it's for
our culture  is the DFL to work e.g.
there is a search everywhere and then
there is somehow well it must make sense
like that and I also at the DFL there is now
with the pernauber for example someone
who I think will do a great job then there
are others  The
protagonists are now also the ones from
Frankfurt and KODi, who help the DFL now,
so I don’t think you should
offer yourself anywhere or anything, but
when the phone rings then
you deal with topics,
but I think that we also deal
with a few specific topics in the  To be
able to support the political sector in the economic but in the sporting is an incredibly
great honor, so
yes, I am a tomcat, I am an athlete,
so I have the dream of the Olympic
Paralympic Games in Germany, so
if I could help then
I would somehow walk to Frankfurt  there
are other areas
where we can certainly improve communication in Berlin, also in the
area of ​​politics,
and to be able to
do both, and by the way
we have now
won Leipzig-Halle Airport, we have
won the German giga network, we
somehow have work for solid wood  Möbel
Hartmann und Kleiner Mitte is a regular
customer from the Münsterland region who is incredibly
happy, so other things
are in the pipeline, we can
certainly do another campaign in the field of generic marketing
in sports this year,
so there are many topics and
it is such
an incredible honor and  Duty
to serve these customers at the same time and
that's our job for the next few years
I have the feeling I have the
hope that we will still see and experience you again
somewhere in an active capacity
and
that will definitely
be entertaining in some way and  probably
also successful and maybe even take a
look for Schalke yes we
both can maybe become Körner
because I think there are currently just
under 300 active Körner in Germany
so maybe we can both still
be Olympic champions there is a
Hamburg in Hamburg even
if  If we have a green team tomorrow then there is a
one in 13 chance
that we might be for Germany, so
I think
we should think about it, so we'll
definitely stay tuned to your projects,
thank you very much for coming in
and yes,
hopefully see you again in a few years  then bye
bye
[music]